some movies begin setting up see cause
during the first film promising even
greater adventures with characters
audiences are just getting to know but
sometimes for a variety of reasons this
doesn't always work out and audiences
are left hanging awaiting a next chapter
that will likely never happen
for example Fantastic Four Fox Studios
2015 reboot of Fantastic Four had a
famously troubled production and it's
been suggested by both cast and crew
that studio meddling kept director Josh
Trank from making the film he wanted to
make well the film are an interesting
take on the team's abilities and
featured a stellar cast it was a
resounding box office and critical
failure despite all this Fox insisted in
the aftermath they were going ahead with
a sequel even setting a 2017 release
date before taking it off the schedule
three months after the film's release
the film's ending certainly set up a
sequel because we're a team now and
there's four of us so we should come up
with a name for it but for now the
screen fate of Marvel's first family
appears to be a limbo our producer
commented in early 2017 that Fox would
not make another Fantastic Four movie
until it was ready to be made which
could mean anything John Carter attempts
to adapt Edgar Rice Burroughs classic
Martian series of novels have been many
and varied and they usually begin and
end in development hell in 2009 rights
holder Disney pinned their hopes on
writer and director Andrew Stanton the
man at the helm of a few Pixar hits who
had a grand vision for films based on
the first three books of the series but
audiences who had no idea who John
Carter was or why they should care
stayed away in droves and the
super-expensive flick contributed to
Disney taking an 84 million dollar loss
by quarter despite the film's sequel
teasing ending and Stanton's plans
Disney scrapped the entire idea even
going so far as to allow the film rights
to revert back to Burroughs estate
Masters of the Universe in 1985 the
live-action adaptation of Masters of the
Universe based on an insanely popular
he-man toy line and animated series was
the answer to every young boy's dream
starring Dolph Lundgren it looks
guaranteed to rake in the cash and spawn
endless sequels and it seemed to confirm
this with
very early example of the post-credits
teaser Skeletor emerges from the pit of
goo and tells the audience and no
uncertain terms that he'll be back but
it was not meant to be the Cannon Films
production was constantly in danger of
going broke cuts were made wherever they
possibly could be and the final fight
between he-man and Skeletor takes place
in the dark for a reason producers were
literally shutting down the production
while cameras were rolling
despite this production actually began
on a sequel but it was scrapped and it
sets and costumes were recycled for the
1989 jean-claude van Damme flick cyborgs
Freddy vs. Jason despite its numerous
flaws the 2003 crossover movie Freddy
vs. Jason pretty much gave fans exactly
what they came to say crazy
you got what you wanted to pull Freddie
oh no he's fighting Jason come on what
what do you want the sight of the two
towering Titans of the slasher genre
beating the holy hell out of each other
helped to make up for any shortcomings
and the film's ending left no doubt that
Freddy even though he lost wasn't done
with Jason by a long shot
but unfortunately any of those fans
still waiting for a cinematic around to
are going to be waiting a long a long
time there are many reasons for this
including most notably that new line
actually had to buy the rights to Friday
the 13th in order to get the crossover
made and paramount long ago we acquired
those rights so don't hold your breath
horror fans Mac and me although it came
and went with practically nobody
noticing in 1988 Mac and me has become
infamous since the advent of YouTube it
has been called both the most brazen et
ripoff ever and a 90-minute commercial
for McDonald's and coke scenes like this
show-stopping McDonald's dance party and
this ridiculous clip which frequently
shows up in compilations of the very
worst film scenes of all time elevate
the film from simple cash into some kind
of surreal capitalist trash masterpiece
the film ends with out will be back
teased as the producers were obviously
expecting the money to come rolling in
but the film grossed only a measly 6.4
million dollars Green Lantern 20 11th
Green Lantern wasn't ambitious expensive
and ultimately failed attempts by Warner
Brothers to make something happen with a
DC property that isn't about man or
Superman
but despite the casting of the
likeable Ryan Reynolds in the total role
and a 200 million dollar budget the film
was a complete mess the result of being
plagued with bad decisions and studio
interference from the beginning the
film's post-credits sequence hinted that
Sinestro would be the villain for the
sequel but Green Lantern's critical and
box office performance forced Warner
Brothers to rethink their strategy and a
rebooted Green Lantern film won't be
arriving until 2020 by which point
Warner Brothers is hoping that fans will
have forgotten about this one
join me thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out his cool stuff we
know you'll love thing
[Music]